spider-man no way home's production cost
a whopping 200 million dollars but that
didn't stop the cast from goofing off
breaking props and ruining multiple
takes here are the best and most
hilarious onset bloopers from no way
home
number one tom holland can do all sorts
of flips and tricks and yet these
bloopers show that he is still a very
clumsy peter
parker he even needed zendaya to catch
him for this one scene
let's save me mj
i thought it was supposed to be the
other way around it's so nice to be
caught for a chance
at least he was totally smooth when he
slipped during this take in the hallway
number two tom holland's brother harry
actually filmed a scene for no way home
but it was deleted the scene saw him
dangling upside down for quite a bit and
the brothers couldn't help but have some
fun with the situation
should we do the kiss
number three the floor in the sanctum
sanctorum is covered in snow for the
film which provided a very slippery
surface for the actors to work on
someone forgot to do the monthly
maintenance spell to keep the seals
tight benedict cumberbatch kept slipping
on the fake snow
that's right he did and you can actually
see him slip in the final cut of the
film tom holland also fell victim to the
slippery stuff sorry
wow number four no way home broke open
the multiverse and brought in multiple
versions of spider-man but what about
other versions of ned what would they be
like
there's other nets out there i wonder
what they're like that's exactly what
jacob battallon was wondering when he
improvised some lines about the
possibilities of meds from alternate
universes like
that is like in nebraska and you're
number five is tom holland actually
spider-man in real life
you got a spider web on you that's
because i'm spider-man
this blooper of a real spider web
attached to his person might be proof of
his superhuman abilities
i think i couldn't leave that one
number six andrew garfield and toby
maguire had never worked together before
no way home but you would think they
were old friends from these clips
[Applause]
peter 2 and peter 3 were having a blast
on set ruining multiple takes with their
constant laughter and loving attitude
it is weird staring at you for that long
number seven sometimes you start
laughing and just can't stop that seemed
to be tom holland's case during the
scene where he is supposed to be having
a conversation with mj
you've been rolling this off
we can't figure out why he was laughing
but at one point it definitely sounds
like he's imitating a cat
number eight tom holland had a very
specific and interesting way of
describing the villains he was facing in
the film electric man a sound man
there's a dinosaur man
and it had both him and marisa tomei
cracking up by the end of the take
wow that was so good
again
number nine all three peter parker's
regrouping on the statue of liberty was
a pretty hilarious scene and all three
actors would agree as they couldn't stop
laughing during each take wait wait wait
wait i love you guys
especially tom holland who couldn't help
but crack up every time andrew garfield
spoke
you're kidding
number 10 well you know what they say an
eye for an eye andrew garfield wasn't
going to be pelted with bread and just
take that carb-loaded abuse sitting down
instead he returned the favor to
zendaya's nj
number 11 this entire cast sure love to
dance a lot
you know the characters probably could
have just settled their differences with
a dance-off
number 12 one of spider-man's main
powers is his superhuman strength
one of andrew garfield's main weaknesses
is his very normal human strength
awkwardly trying to lift up jamie foxx
who was draped in electro guard
[Music]
spidey number 13 this film is rated
pg-13 but all of the actors cursing
habits behind the scenes would suggest
otherwise
cut zendaya even made sure to get in a
not too nice gesture
number 14 there was a ton of wire and
rigging work done on the set of this
movie to provide the proper movement
needed to make the actors look
flawlessly cool but sometimes the wires
would betray them like when tom holland
swung a little too freely
or when jamie foxx put a little too much
oomph into pantomiming electro's blast
attack
number 15. tom holland wasn't the only
clumsy spider-man on set andrew garfield
had his own moment when his mask slipped
out of his hand and the wires he was
hooked up to prevented him from grabbing
it i'm sorry
so he did what any good spider-man would
do and gave off whatever
all of these bloopers could make a movie
of their own we can't get enough of
seeing all these actors together on set
having a good time which blooper did you
find most hilarious let us know in the
comments and thanks for stopping by at
the things